>> Dana: JOE BIDEN
REPORTEDLY FEELING BURNED BY
FORMER BOSS ACCORDING TO
VANITY FAIR THE FORMER V.P.
UPSET OVER BARACK OBAMA
MEETING WITH OTHER POTENTIAL
2020 CONTENDERS LIKE BETO
O’ROURKE BEFORE HE HAS
OFFICIALLY MADE HIS
DECISION.
BIDEN SPOKESPERSON PUSHING
BACK AGAINST THE AGAINST THE
STORY CALLING IT
UNEQUIVOCALLY FALSE.
HE MAY HAVE OTHER OBSTACLES
IN HIS WAY.
59% OF DEMOCRATIC AND
INDEPENDENT VOTERS ARE
EXCITED FOR SOMEONE ENTIRELY
NEW TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
BIDEN COMES IN SECOND
FOLLOWED BY BERNIE SANDERS
AND BETO O’ROURKE.
AND 70% OF THOSE SAME VOTERS
SAY HILLARY CLINTON SHOULD
NOT RUN AGAIN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP GOING AFTER
DEMOCRATS AS WE HAVE MORE OF
THAT?
NO WHY DON’T.
IS THAT JUST A POLL.
THE TELEPROMPTER IS WORKING
VERY WELL TODAY.
MARIA HARF.
EVEN IF BIDEN WERE UPSET HE
WOULDN’T SAY SO.
IT’S OBVIOUS THAT IS GOING
TO HAVE TO MEET WITH LOTS OF
DEMOCRATS BEFORE 2020,
RIGHT?
>> YES.
I ACTUALLY DON’T THINK, I
MEAN JOE BIDEN IS AN ADULT.
HE HAS BEEN IN POLITICS A
LONG TIME.
HE AND BARACK OBAMA ARE VERY
CLOSE.
I DON’T THINK HE IS PROBABLY
VERY UPSET ABOUT THIS.
IT’S INTERESTING THOUGH IN
THAT POLL 59% WANT SOMEONE
NEW.
I THINK WE SEE THAT IN POET
PARTIES, RIGHT?
THAT’S HOW WE GOT DONALD
TRUMP.
BUT JOE BIDEN WAS AT 53%.
JOE BIDEN KNOWS HE IS VERY
POPULAR IN THE PARTY.
IS HE POPULAR AMONG
INDEPENDENTS AND BARACK
OBAMA IS GOING TO HAVE TO
MEET WITH LOTS OF PEOPLE I
DO DO THINK YOU WILL SEE
KEEP HIS POWDER DRY NOT HAVE
25, 30 PEOPLE WEIGH IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY.
IF JOE BIDEN WANTS TO RUN,
JOE BIDEN WILL HAVE A LOT OF
SUPPORT EVEN AMONG PEOPLE
BARACK OBAMA EVEN IF HE
DIDN’T DOESN’T ENDORSE HIM
HE WAS VICE PRESIDENT 8
YEARS.
HE HAS THICKER SKIN THAN
THAT.
>> HE WAS THE VICE PRESIDENT
THE LAST ELECTION AS WELL.
WEAVE KNOW THE PARTY
LEADERSHIP AS WELL AS THE
PRESIDENT ALL DID THE GARDEN
MEETINGS.
HE WASN’T GOING TO RUN.
THIS WAS ALL BECAUSE HILLARY
CLINTON WAS THE CHOSEN
CANDIDATE.
>> Maria: THAT’S NOT WHY
BIDEN DIDN’T RUN.
LAWRENCE
>> I DO THINK HE WILL BE
FRUSTRATED IF THE PRESIDENT
DOESN’T GET BEHIND HIM.
HE UNDERSTANDS FORMER
PRESIDENT HE HAS TO BE WITH
ALL THE CANDIDATES.
THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT IS
GOING TO BE EXPECTED,
PRESIDENT OBAMA, TO GET
BEHIND HIM BECAUSE HE DID
STEP ASIDE AND LET HILLARY
CLINTON RUN.
>> IT’S NOT EASY TO TELL
SOMEBODY THAT MAYBE IT’S
PAST THEIR TIME.
RIGHT?
IT’S NOT EASY TO TELL
SOMEONE THAT.
WE ARE NOT ELEPHANTS.
>> YOU SEE THE WORD,
PERSONALITY ABOUT THE
REPUBLICANS THAT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS NOW
APERSONALITY AND IT’S ALL
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
I THINK THAT IS NOT TRUE.
THE CULTIVE PERSONALITY IS.
ANTI-TRUMP PARTY THAT’S ALL
THEY ARE AT THIS POINT.
THAT’S WHY THEY NEED A NEW
PERSON.
DEFINITELY PERSONALITY.
THEY LIKED HIS PERSONALITY.
THEY WANTED DONALD TRUMP.
IT WASN’T ANYONE NEW.
SO, THEY ARE SEARCHING
FOR -- THAT’S WHY BETO IS
SUCH A BIG THING.
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT REALLY
SURE ABOUT WHY THEY LIKE HIM
BUT THEY THINK HE IS A
PERSONALITY THAT CAN TAKE ON
TRUMP.
THAT’S ALL THEY WANT.
>> Dana: THEY WANT SOMEONE
WHO HAS A SPARK.
>> Morgan: MAYBE.
I’M LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS
PRIMARY.
THIS LOOKS LIKE THE
REPUBLICAN PRIMARY TIMES
LIKE 1,000 JUST LIKE GET OUT
THE POPCORN.
I CAN’T WAIT.
WHAT’S IRONIC TO ME IS HOW
THE DEM ACTIVIST BASE
FREAKING OUT TOP THREE
PEOPLE IN POLLING ARE ALL
WHITE MEN.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS BEEN
CRITICIZED NONSTOP BY
DEMOCRATS BY BEING THE PARTY
OF WHITE MEN.
ANY TIME YOU OPPOSE THE
POLICY OF PRESIDENT BARACK
OBAMA IT MUST BE BECAUSE YOU
ARE A RACIST.
NOW THE WOMEN IN THE
MINORITY THAT ARE GOING TO
BE RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
WILL BE TURNING THAT AROUND
ON FELLOW DEMOCRATS.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING HOW
BERNIE AND BIDEN AND
O’ROURKE ANSWER THAT ALL
WHITE MALE WHICH IS ALMOST
LIKE WORSE THAN BEING A
CRIMINAL IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY RIGHT NOW.
>> Dana: WHAT FRUSTRATES ME
ABOUT FELLOW DEMOCRATS IS
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR A
SAVIOR RIGHT NOW.
THAT’S WHY THEY LOOK AT
BETO.
THEY WANT SOMEONE WHO IS A
PERFECT CANDIDATE AND
PERFECT PACKAGE.
>> THEY HAVE ONE IN BARACK
OBAMA.
MARIA I KEEP TELLING MY
FELLOW DEMOCRATS WE DON’T
NEED A SAVIOR.
THE PRIMARY PROCESS
SOMETIMES WORKS ITSELF OUT
IT SOMETIMES PUTS FORWARD A
CANDIDATE THAT CAN WIN IN A
GENERAL.
THE REPUBLICAN PRIMARY WAS
INSANE.
IT PUT FORTH A CANDIDATE
THAT COULD WIN A GENERAL
ELECTIONS SAME WITH BARACK
OBAMA IN 2008.
SOMETIMES THESE PROCESSES
ACTUALLY WORK.
>> Dana: I DO HAVE A
QUESTION FOR YOU, MARIA,
TELL ME JUST ABOUT
LOGISTICALLY HOW YOU THINK
THINGS WILL CHANGE WHEN
CALIFORNIA MOVES EARLIER FOR
THEIR PRIMARY BECAUSE THERE
ARE SO MANY DELEGATES THEN?
DOES THAT CHANGE A LOT?
>> Maria: THAT WILL CHANGE
IT, ALSO THE FACT THAT SUPER
DELEGATES, THESE PARTIES
ELDERS GIVEN A LOT OF POWER
IN PREVIOUS DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY THEY HELPED ANOINT
HILLARY CLINTON FOR EXAMPLE,
THEY HAVE MUCH LESS POWER
NOW.
THE POWER HAS BEEN PUSHED
DOWN TO THE GRASSROOTS
ACTIVISTS.
DEMOCRATS IN IOWA ARE
DIFFERENT THAN DEMOCRATS IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE AND SOUTH
CAROLINA.
NEVADA NOW NO LONGER A
CAUCUS, NOW A PRIMARY.
THESE THINGS SEEM VERY
WONKY, BUT THEY ACTUALLY
MATTER WHEN THERE IS GOING
TO BE A VERY HOTLY CONDITION
TESTED PRIMARY.
THAT’S WHY YOU WILL SEE
CANDIDATES GO TO IOWA AND
NEW HAMPSHIRE.
YOU ALREADY ARE.
THIS PRIMARY IS STARTING
LIKE NOW.
>> Morgan: THE GENERATIONAL
STRUGGLE IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY IS SORT OF A
FASCINATING ONE AS WELL.
AND THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION THEY RELY SO MUCH
ON THE YOUNGER VOTERS THAT
DIDN’T SHOW OUT FOR HILLARY
CLINTON.
ESPECIALLY YOUNGER WOMEN.
AND THE GENERATIONAL
STRUGGLE JUST ISN’T ABOUT
THEIR 2020 NOMINEE.
LOOK AT THE ANGST THAT WAS
GEARED TOWARDS PELOSI AND TO
SCHUMER.
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THEIR 70’S
AND IN LEADERSHIP FOR A LONG
TIME.
YOU ARE SORT OF SEEING THE
BASE OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, ESPECIALLY THE YOUNG
PEOPLE SAY, YOU KNOW, IT’S
OUR TIME TO LEAD.
IT’S OUR TIME FOR
LEADERSHIP.
>> ONE PROBLEM THE DEMOCRATS
ARE GOING TO HAVE IS
AUTHENTIC LEADERSHIP.
A LOT OF CANDIDATES WEREN’T
AS FAR LEFT WHEN THEY WERE
IN OTHER OFFICES, WHEN IT
CAME TO BETO.
>> KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND.
>> HE VOTED FOR LEGISLATION
TO DISMANTLE OBAMACARE.
>> WHY BERNIE HAS BEEN
ATTACKING HIM.
>> KAMALA HARRIS IS FOR
SOCIAL JUSTICE REFORM SHE
DIDN’T GOVERN THAT WAY IN
CALIFORNIA.
LET’S BE CLEAR BIDEN IS AN
EXPERIENCED POLITICIAN.
IS HE NOT GOING TO PLAY FAIR
WITH THEM.
HE GOAL AFTER EVERY SINGLE
THING THAT THEY DID.
>> Maria: I’M READY.
>> RIGHT NOW WHEN IT COMES
TO THE DEMOCRATS, HE IS THE
ONLY CANDIDATE THAT HAS A
SHOT IN THE RUNNING BECAUSE,
HE HAS BEEN THAT CONSISTENT
LEADER.
>> Maria: MARIA POLL NUMBERS
FROM 2015 OR ’11 OR ’07 WE
WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT A
WHOLE DIFFERENT GROUP OF
PEOPLE.
>> ALL THE NUMBERS HAVE TO
DO WITH TROOP.
EVEN 70% DON’T WANT HER TO
RUN.
THEY ARE MAD AT HER BECAUSE
SHE LOST TO TRUMP.
THAT’S WHY HER ANYBODY’S ARE
THAT’S WHY NUMBERS ARE SO
LOW.
>> THEY WILL FORGIVE BETO IF
THEY THINK.
>> I DON’T THINK SO.
>> Dana: EACH THE BERNIE
PEOPLE ARE NOT SOLID BERNIE
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE SAYING YOU HAVE TO
COURT US A LITTLE BIT.
>> Morgan: TO MORGAN’S POINT
THERE IS A GOOD ONE.
PEOPLE SAYING LOOK WE NEED
TO WIN.
SOMEONE LIKE JOE BIDEN OR
BETO CAN WIN.
WE NEED TO WIN WITH A FILL
IN THE BLANK, WOMAN,
MINORITY, PROGRESSIVE,
WHATEVER THAT BLANK IS, AND
YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE
DEMOCRATS WHO SAY JOB NUMBER
ONE IS TO WIN.
WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
DO AND
DO THAT AND TAKE CARE OF THE
REST LATER QUITE FRANKLY.
>> Morgan: POLL WE LOOKED AT
EARLIER 41% OF DEMOCRATS
THOUGHT THAT BERNIE SHOULD
NOT RUN AGAIN.
FOR ME, WHEN YOU SEE.
>> AMEN.
>> HE IS NOT A DEMOCRAT I
SAY THAT ALL THE TIME.
MORGUE MORAL FOR ME, INSTEAD
OF TRYING TO TONYA HARDING
BETO ALREADY IN THE.
>> GOOD REFERENCE.
>> Morgan: I LOOKED HER NAME
UP EARLIER TODAY.
IT’S NOT REALLY ABOUT THAT.
IT’S ABOUT HE IS SELFISH.
IT’S ABOUT POWER.
MORE THAN ABOUT IDEOLOGY.
THEY ARE ALL SO POWER HUNGRY
THEY CAN’T LEAD A MOVEMENT
AND STEP ASIDE.
>> THAT NEW MOVEMENT IS
WHERE THE ENERGY IS.
>> Maria: PART OF IT NOT ALL
OF IT.
>> I SAID THIS YESTERDAY ON
"THE FIVE" WE WOULD LAUGH AT
OCASIO-CORTEZS BUT THEY ARE
WINNING.
NOT JUST HER THAT IS
THERE ARE INCREMENTAL
CHANGES THEY WANT TO MAKE.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TO TAKE
THEM SERIOUS.
THEY ARE THE FREEDOM CAUCUS
OF THE LEFT.
>> Morgan: THEY ARE ONLY
WINNING IN CERTAIN PLACES.
THE WAY WE TOOK BACK THE
MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE IS BY
WINNING MODERATE SEATS IN
KANSAS CITY AND NEVADA AND
DETROIT AND DENVER.
ALL OF THESE PLACES WE TOOK
BACK THE HOUSE WITH
MODERATES.
A LOT OF ATTENTION GOES TO
PROGRESSIVES AND THAT’S THE
FIGHT YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE.
>> Dana: WE HAVE TO RUN,
GUYS.
DO YOU HAVE ANY LAST